well yeah it's the end of the world but
you got a laugh right hello there folks
in yes I have now seen all six episodes
of Good Omens now I had been planning to
get to this regardless but honestly
would be with the backlog of stuff that
I've been trying to get to and catch up
on and a bunch of other stuff I wasn't
sure I was gonna get to it right away
that call got made for me because this
is in fact a patreon sponsored review so
that moved it up the docket to basically
as soon as I could get it out and so
let's talk about it now Good Omens is of
course based on the novel by the same
name which was written in collaboration
between Terry Pratchett and Neil Gaiman
now Neil now Terry Pratchett is sadly
passed away Neil Gaiman wrote the
scripts for this and was an executive
producer and I have read the original
book it's been a while it's been
probably close to 20 years since I've
read it so this is not gonna be a case
where I can lay out for you what the
differences are what I can tell you is
nearly everything that I remembered not
quite everything but nearly everything I
remembered showed up in some form in the
show so this really feels like one of
those adaptations that is trying to just
directly translate the original work to
a new medium as faithfully as is
possible this is not a reimagining this
is not like oh well we'll include some
stuff before and a little stuff after
and like a side plot that wasn't it's
not that kind of thing I couldn't really
remember but apparently from what I saw
the Archangel Gabriel which is the
character played by John hand John Hamm
wasn't really in the book much but
Gaiman says that the characterization of
him was something that he had discussed
with Pratchett that I can't remember if
it was either they wanted to introduce
him and possibly a follow-up book or if
they were gonna have him in go-to
and ultimately decide to cut him
whatever it was this wasn't something at
least according to him that he created
out a whole cloth for the show it was an
adaptation of stuff that he'd done with
practices that just didn't make the
original novel so what is the plot of
this thing in case you don't know if you
haven't read the book which honestly you
should although I'll flashback to my
video that I did before about whether
you should read books or see the
adaptations first this is one of those
cases where I really think you should
see the adaptation first because since
it is so faithful reading the book is
just gonna give you the more complete
experience because some stuff still gets
trimmed I can even cite a couple of
specific things that were like oh I
liked it a little better with how the
book did it um you know stuff that had
stuck in my memory so but it is so
faithful that the adaptation is a
slightly simplified version so I
recommend seeing that first so that you
can enjoy that and then read the book
and get even more if you read the book
first assuming you haven't read it
already then you are gonna do what I did
which is good which is have little mom
and stuff oh they didn't they didn't use
the mmm which I mean annoys me that I
had that feeling at a couple of points
in this show because it's really good so
plot the plot is basically uh it's the
end of the world as in the classic
biblical end of the world we are dealing
with Armageddon here we are dealing with
the Antichrist coming to usher in the
end of the world the son of Satan is on
earth the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse are being summoned the the
Leviathan you know they call it the
Kraken but like great beasts from from
the ocean or rising you know this this
is the end game it's going on but see
there's two people there's an angel and
there's a demon who had been on earth
for pretty much the whole time the
planets been here and they well never
technically been on the same side of
anything they've been around each other
enough that yeah they're friends and
that is cross are Crowley he changes his
name for some reason his original name
stuck with me more but there's Crowley
played by David Tennant who is of course
demon and there is a zero fail who is
played by Michael Sheen obviously they
are almost polar opposites in terms of
look characterization approach to things
and the the two of them are looking
around at earth and everything that's
going on they spot a couple of things
about Armageddon that aren't actually
going exactly as they were supposed to
and then that they and then they realize
we kind of don't want the world to end
we like the world and we like it here
and we think these people deserve better
so they then set about trying to figure
out how do you foil the apocalypse like
the biblical apocalypse well that's your
story that's your basic story anyway
there are a lot of other characters that
appear in this you have the descendant
of an incredibly accurate prophet who is
following the nice and accurate
prophecies of Agnes Nutter she's like
her great-great great-great-great I
forget how many greats it is
granddaughter following these prophecies
you know trying to do her best by them
and and achieve the best goals out of
what these sometimes difficult to
interpret prophecies are telling her she
encounters a very haphazard would-be
computer engineer who seems to just be
poisoned to technology on now that young
man has fallen in line with the last
remaining Witchfinder the witch finders
used to be a whole organization who
found witches but he's basically the
last one left that characters played by
Michael McKean I apologize for not
mentioning the actors for the other one
I'm probably gonna only mention the
actors who's who I knew from other stuff
but you know he is he's basically just
kind of very it's a formality the fact
that he's even still around and he's
technically running the Witchfinder army
but he recruits this young this young
man so he gets roped into that there is
there is sort of a soothsayer character
who's a charlatan and she's not legit
but she's in the mix there is the
aforementioned
Antichrist and his three friends so you
have this little troupe of four kids
that have a dynamic not dissimilar to
like I don't know it or stranger things
or stand by me you know it's that kind
of they just mesh well together these
are really good friends and then you
have other angels like I had mentioned
Jon Hamm as Gabriel you've got other
angels beside that you've got other
demons you there's a lot going on but
for how many characters there are this
is a pretty dang good job of presenting
and streamlining more or less the
entirety of the book in about six hours
it's really well done and the visuals
are quite nice as well I think well I'd
say there is actually possibility for if
they wanted to do a follow-up of some
manner there's enough you know at the
end that you probably put together
something but this is a complete
experience which is probably why it
looks so good because they're going in
again I suspect there's some people
somewhere like maybe if it's good enough
we get to do more but like this is being
presented as a complete experience and
sort of knowing that they get film you
know film caliber actors and roles
people who don't often do a lot of TV or
if they do it's only like a few guest
spots so you know it's really really
well together piece that the kind that
you don't get that often anymore because
not many networks be they streaming or
traditional television do the basically
the limited miniseries anymore
everything is intended to be an ongoing
franchise for as long as possible cuz I
can remember back in like you know when
I was a kid
eighties nineties and honestly before
that even you know there were things
like roots and Lonesome Dove and you
know not always things that I or
honestly the original it that was
basically in miniseries it was two TV
movies so this kind of we're gonna spend
more money on this than you'd normally
see in a TV series but it's gonna have
the breathing room at the time that you
wouldn't get from a movie that in some
ways feels a bit like a dying art
because since they want the
most studios want the projects to keep
going ad infinitum they will kind of put
a spending cap ters it like we can't
spend everything on this because we need
to have somewhere to go if we need to up
the budget in the next season but this
isn't designed like that so it's it's
nice and it's a very complete
presentation and all the performances
are good honestly the standout for me as
much as I love Tennant and he's great in
this kind of devil-may-care fast-talking
role I wonder why he's so good at that
but honestly the standout for me was
Michael Sheen a zero fail is so
endearing he's so neurotic he's he's so
second guessing of himself but he's so
sweet
oh my gosh I love him to death but all
the performances are really good and
Tenant don'twell tendon gets the bonus
up not only does he get to tear but
around in this really awesome vintage
car but he gets to do it
pretty much always while listening to
Queen and you can't go wrong listening
to Queen as far as I'm concerned so that
that's great stuff the kids are quite
good isn't it like that could've easily
been a stumbling point because young
actors playing anything heavy is always
potentially gonna be a rough ride and
like especially the kid who plays Adam
he's got a lot of weight to pull and he
does it pretty well um it's not like
amazing I mean I'm kind of glad they had
other stuff to cut too if they if the
whole series was him like it might not
held up but for how much the character
is in it yeah it works and and he's
solid and is dynamic with the other kids
is good we've also got a voiceover
narration from Francis McDormand
and that is sort of the the series way
of injecting a little bit of the
narrative voice from the novel because
they talked a little bit about this when
I did my video on Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy now one of the big things you
lose in translating a literary medium
into a visual one of any kind whether
it's movies or TV or honestly even an
audio one is you lose the authorial
voice because you can certainly keep the
dialogue you keep character voices but
the way that things are described the
word choices and the analogies made in
the telling of the narrow
that tends to get lost and terry
pratchet i would actually in some ways
call him about the fantasy equivalent to
doug he is the fantasy with Douglas
Adams in science fiction at least from
my not having read a ton of Terry
Pratchett but from what I've read I feel
safe in that comparison and in both
cases they do a lot of great work in
terms of just giving the gist the
description of something that little
extra flavor and in that and not to
downplay Neil Gaiman's contributions but
having read a lot of Neil Gaiman and a
little bit more Pratchett Good Omens
tonally is much more in keeping with
Pratchett and the feeling I get is that
Gaiman sort of adapted his style to fit
Pratchett more than Pratchett adapted to
fit him so I do feel totally it is much
more in keeping with Pratchett than in
Gaiman because Damon while he does have
his own style he's also a writer for
hire and he can and has been a bit more
of a chameleon and he can and has
adopted other tones from other writers
if he felt the need to and I kind of
feel like that's what he he did here so
we do get to keep a little bit of that
kind of flavour through the voiceovers
and the narration from Francis McDormand
um that said like there are like I said
there are tiny little things that I'm
like oh but I thought really stuck in my
head ah nuts I like nothing substantive
nothing like significant or applaud or
like a Man Thing out that character
wrong um although my my vision for death
I don't mean visually but in terms of
the performance doesn't quite line up
with what we got here but then again
it's been so long since I read it I
don't know if I'm remembering it wrong
sorry I can't make that comparison but
like so like the one thing I'll feel
comfortable talking about so I mentioned
the nice and accurate prophecies of
Agnes Nutter now the way it's presented
in the show is basically that she just
knew all this stuff and wrote it down
and she just seemed to know like all of
it now that's not to say it negates the
way that it's presented in the novel but
I'd like the ways presented a novel a
little bit better and it's never sort of
laid out that way in the show because
the ways laid out in the novel is
there's actually comparison made it's
like she's looking at an atlas through a
straw so she's seeing things and knowing
exactly what they are knowing when they
happen but like she has no context for
any of it and she's writing down
prophecies that may not be important
whatsoever like the example that's given
is on the date that Kennedy was
assassinated the prophecy that she wrote
referred to a tree falling over in
England because her concern was her own
descendants so she was concerned that
one of them might be in that part of
England when that tree fell over so
that's what she wrote down and and the
show doesn't really have that the so
basically has all prophecies are helpful
and and obviously this one we just
basically knew everything was going on
and I you boy using gamer terminology it
makes Agnes Nutter a little o P a little
overpowered whereas like they kind of
she's a little bit more nerfed in the
way it's presented in the book and I
kind of preferred that but like those
kinds of things are Nick picks and
they're only knit picks that I have
because I read the book if I hadn't run
the book honestly I don't think I have
anything to complain about this because
by the time it was done I was just
smiling I was just happy like this was
time well spent watching this show and
it left me at a good place which was
good cuz some stuffs been going on
lately that like has not had me in a
good place but this this show about the
end of the world that doesn't sugarcoat
it or present the fact that the world is
ending has something to laugh at
still managed to cheer me up quite a bit
so take that as your your bullet point
review I think I managed to avoid
spoilers while still talking about what
I liked so we'll wrap it up there Good
Omens you seen it yet what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments
let's talk about it whole bunch of stuff
down there to do because you can support
the show through patreon likes that
those help subscribe if you haven't
already that's much appreciated as well
plus there's links to merch I got stuff
up for Pride and and all that so then
click the links check it out or don't
you don't have to folks cuz as much as I
appreciate it at the end of the day
you're the council
I'm just running meetings and until next
time
so is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]